hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play gary dark
secrets you ready are you ready
Oda laughs if that didn't work if that
was like wrong you did that the wrong
way he's gonna fall down again oh I hit
myself on the desk oh that wasn't cool
man Gary you bastard oh oh yeah oh man I
don't think I've ever seen one that
close before Oh Howie I like that when i
adjure k-- and my ribs like cracked
right into the corner of my desk Oh
or the edge okay
oh where am i it's really dark I better
wait where's my flashlight oh [ __ ] no no
no I know back Oh calm down damn it it
has to be somewhere around there mm-hmm
does it have to be some damn door ah
stop being such a baby
I just stared uh I guess you did too but
I steered a big old monster right in the
face
well wouldn't it happen if you didn't
find your flashlight Hey look a lantern
Laborde I managed to keep the batteries
at least you need a flashlight for you
dele not a image Ana's imaginaries tabal
artists I don't think that means guest
quarters may might be I don't know I'm
not oh boy
okay I don't think that was a real one
I like the custom user can smell it
didn't turn into anything like overtly
dramatic
[Music]
well my flashlights none here up Plus
this OH
mush hey rat look at tinderbox open with
force dim the box there we go alright
not in here hello monster monster Oh
storage
I think I think the author just found
things it kind of seemed like they might
be the words I think there's key over by
the fire oh I've nowhere
I have nowhere oh oh behind the boxes
perfect ah oh he's so bad I'm at a
diamond not ten ways from Sunday I'm
gonna die fifteen ways from Friday I
might die 23 and a half ways from your
house to mine door wasn't even open
buddy are we close open close I don't
know the door all got themselves I'm so
boat oh I'm I'm so oh I just screwed
myself
no no [ __ ] up I'm up on up would you
can't see me
[Music]
that's the spawn noise okay
ah [ __ ] this up bad but okay that's okay
that's fine I'm okay with that
maybe I should scar and confront them Oh
najin couldn't write that up you can't
see me
Wow I just cover my eyes you go away oh
my god he didn't see me
what the hell wha I'll believe it please
leave now you're not welcome here
wha what the hell
move this how can I move this I'm not
gonna try all right now anyway oh okay
I seems gone man I can't believe that
actually worked
I got away from him by just standing
there like a lump all right then okay
everything seems hunky-dory
ah there was a saw right here Chris I
saw him in half
well I wouldn't have worked but okay Oh
take that as a victory yeah I'm the best
get chin at least that's world Hey
didn't get anything from that room I
don't think I did let me double check I
didn't have time to search there must be
something here oh yeah key in the fire
that's right so I need to put out the Oh
fires out he is oh no it's not he is too
hot to carry good thing I just put my
hand on that maybe cool it off with some
vulture you shut it up with your crazy
ideas
not shut up shut it up lots of mini gear
okay I don't see any water here giant
hammer
Pusha bowling for some reason it's
possible [ __ ] off okay so I can't get in
the kitchen I don't have any water
my whole life's just in shambles I don't
have my flashlight either oh hello
better find another way down you're not
even gonna let me it's like an invisible
wall here I'm trying to I'm trying to
jump down I could take it for this guy's
just a giant pansy
so we'll go around we'll find some
wah-wah-wah so that we can put it on a
fire cuz I'm such a big baby I can't
pick up a hot key whatever and no one
make any comments about how is this
cowering in fear no one make a comment
okay
so I need like to find them a
bowl-shaped device with which to inject
water into the oh hello ah I did not spy
this at first there's a room back here
underneath all of the debris I'm so
strong maybe up up up ah that torch come
in handy in dark place
ah you think the darkness is your ally
merely adopted the dark I was born in it
folded by it I didn't know see the light
until I was already man ah Ariel a nice
convenient bucket of water yeah I still
don't have my thingamabob er also known
as a flashlight don't know where it
could have gone that wasn't a real one
the fakey fake monster job you roaches
no one likes you
everyone told me behind your back
they think you're an annoyance okay get
the wah-wah torch
oh hello a note tomorrow is the day of
my grand party it's going to be a blast
after all I am the host so what else
would you expect if those fools only
have the slightest idea of my real
intended for this so-called party well
then I don't think my body would be
nearly as lively as I hope to say the
least
either way they will know soon enough
for now I need to make some more
preparations for tomorrow Oh Thomas
those two the party but isn't that
Thomas yes it said Thomas's diary
okay so I got this big red hot thing
don't know why torch what the hell
seriously why do I just throw the torch
what I mean seriously why oh I get it
oh well really this this is how I hold
it I've never seen this done before but
it's interesting to say the least
skew to the door of course I do on my
gamma of it hi for the atmosphere but
that's for you guys hello picked up
rusty key hey hey what done fire you
don't belong in the fire your fire stop
being so silly so now I'm guessing that
was the kitchen key just guessing just
slinging out a guess oh yeah oh yeah
footprints big footprints long
footprints you know what they say I
don't know what they say but they say it
and they say it Louden what where'd my
Gorge go it was in my hand
oh there is I don't need morphine
sacks of potatoes
okay there's something in here
nope just dead things bill this isn't a
very good kitchen you know wouldn't meet
standards call a health inspector on
your ass
that said guest quarters before wine
cellar anything under the stairs here
seems to be what's this hello
morphine is that morphine that's
sedatives ah that makes more sense than
a sanity potion go the quarters cuz I'm
a fool now let's go to the wine cellar
bring it on
I'm ready for you I'm casting a shadow
there was it that lantern from the light
of the Sun damn it
alright I guess I'll go the other way
fine
Oh anybody home
there's my flashlight yeah
[Music]
okay that's all the time I got for this
episode thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye bye